all my fans know that I am a true crime
fanatic I think about murder all the
time I know that sounds nefarious and it
is by the way uh but uh I'm obsessed
with True Crime and so
um I'm very excited right now because I
have the opportunity to sit with the
person who I consider to be the queen
slash king of uh all True Crime uh
Ashley flowers from crime junkie Ashley
welcome so nice to meet you I'm so glad
to be here yeah I mean I I I've been I
think I work murder into most of the
conversations we have so would you say
that's fair just your overall dialogue
you say murder murder a lot to just even
strangers I mutter a murderer a lot
um yeah I I I've
um I've been since I was a kid
fascinated and so uh and I'm a big fan
of yours and very uh thrilled for your
incredible success which is well
deserved when did you start thinking
about True Crime murder was this a
childhood thing well it was I grew up
like when my mom would read to me the
fiction stuff Nancy Drew then we
graduated Agatha Christie and then at
some point I realized that these stories
weren't all fiction and that the the
murders and stuff that we were reading
about could really happen in real life
and I think you know
JonBenet when I was real little that's
when I first started I was I always say
tabloid height I was like looking at
that and I think that I started so you
were a similar age and you thought wait
a minute this happened to someone who
looks real life looks a little like me
in real life yeah and so and then I
started realizing more and more that
these cases were actually happening and
I was just fascinated so I always say my
mom was the OG crime junkie her mom
before her and I also someone just
brought this up to me the other day and
I literally had like this aha moment
where I grew up super religious like no
Harry Potter no Furbies no Cabbage Patch
Kids I don't know what was wrong with
cabbage patch oh really religious wait
so Harry Potter Harry Potter well
Furbies I can see are demonic but you
got
yeah we forbade that in our home too but
you're not even religious oh please I'm
very very religious oh okay yeah devout
Methodist uh no wait wait a minute
you're Catholic well same thing
eventually
um
there's a voice in the sky and I'm
trying to be a good person
that's all it was
a voice in the sky
um but moving on so so you you yeah I
couldn't do a lot of things and so I
think that one of the reasons someone
pointed out maybe you were so invested
in this is because this was one of the
the things that we could read or watch
or whatever for whatever reason that was
allowed and so possibly that's one of
the reasons I was so deeply invested
that's so interesting so you find
something that you love absolutely love
that fascinates you and you feel like
you were put on this Earth to do it and
then you get to make a living doing that
that is it's truly it's a miracle know
that that is so rare and I say it all
the time that I I don't it feels like
work sometimes but I love every second
of it I have never worked harder or more
in my entire life but I've never been
happier I'm curious is there a certain
kind of profile
of a killing that interests you more
than others
I'm definitely drawn to unsolved cases
right because I feel like there's
something I can do and that's kind of
been the theme of the whole reason I
started this is I was looking for what
can I do where I'm just consuming
consuming consuming I felt like I was
taking and taking and taking from the
True Crime community and I wanted to
give back so unsolved cases I also which
my audience I think [ __ ] hates but I
was really drawn to uh crimes with
children yeah I was never
a fan of us of a crime story that
involved a child but then once you have
kids it's you know and I think Sona you
have kids now you have a child it's like
you just I have two kids I just said a
child
yeah eight child who I really respect
and then that other guy
I love them both to death but
um to death uh
but I um I don't think we're meant to
understand the concept of the end of the
universe uh or the end of time and we're
not our brains are not meant to
understand how someone could do that
I'm also really interested by missing
persons cases like this idea that
someone can be there living their life
and then just vanish Into Thin Air which
obviously is not what happened it's on
alien abduction but that there's no
Trace is is mind-boggling to me yeah
yeah are you fascinated by this world of
True Crime I think you know I am I mean
I feel like you and I first bonded
because of our shared fascination with
this murder and that's right when we
first we I interviewed Sona she uh chose
her to be my assistant we all make
mistakes okay and um okay well whatever
you know I was young and foolish and uh
it's middle-aged and foolish no but uh I
swear to God and and son is being super
professional and I'm being professional
as the boss and we had we happened to be
driving someplace the next thing I know
stop you and I are driving up yeah lclo
that was your interview no no this was
after the interview
like right this wasn't part of the yeah
this is how I now want to get in big
trouble let me drive you to the house I
was like I can't tell this is a dream or
like the biggest red flag
I would love it if this was the
interview yeah of the nine people I took
to the Sharon Tate crime scene only one
seemed interested so she's got the job
you realize she can't read
she doesn't have she doesn't know how to
work a computer oh my God uh no
um no it was after you were hired but I
remembered we were both finishing each
other's sentences yeah and that's when
when True Crime people find each other
um we can finish each other's sentences
and I'm sure you've had that many times
you meet people and you know they're in
lockstep with you yeah you're just it's
the stuff that you've been dying to talk
about but you don't want to be the
weirdo in the room usually and so when
you find somebody who you can have those
conversations with it feels amazing yeah
and I think it's also just being in Los
Angeles too I feel like LA's so rich
with just like serial murderers and all
these like fascinated Twisted murder
stories it's almost like it's just in
the air sometimes that's a good ad for
La
come to L.A
murders in the air murders in the air
you know it is I have to say when I
first came out here a million years ago
to start my career I came to LA right
out of college and I remembered
um driving around and feeling there is
an uh it's such a sprawling place with
these long highways and it does feel
like there's a reason that you know
Richard Ramirez thrived here like that
that that there are certain
there's a certain kind of killer that
almost thrives in the way that La is
constructed does that make sense yeah
because you can just disappear and you
can do you know what I mean you can come
from anywhere you get there La is filled
with so many people who weren't from
here and and things can feel rootless
and creepy if you're driving out in the
outer reaches of La there was a guy back
in the 60s named Mac Ray Edwards and he
uh uh killed children and he actually
buried them in the freeways in L.A he
worked construction and so they're like
still there and they'll never dig them
up because it's too expensive they can't
shut down the roadways it's wild
that sense I never heard about this
yeah we did a whole episode on him it
was Unreal
do you this is a very specific question
but in all of your thinking and all of
your
um uh you know work that you've done on
this do you is there an effective way to
get rid of a body or like a really
effective way clearly everyone I would
think burying a body would be oh that's
great who's going to find that they
always find it they always find it and
animals find I mean you'd have to go
pretty deep in a pretty remote spot
um
water seems to be pretty effective very
deep water if you can like really weight
it down okay I'm writing this down
who I worked with for a long time and he
was like if you ever need to get rid of
a body there's this marshy area in
Indianapolis and I'm like why are you
telling me this he's like trust me yeah
trust me it never lets me down it's it's
like yeah you got to find the places
that are just like hard to get you
throwing people like over canyons and if
you can just make it somewhere that
isn't easily accessible even if police
have an idea
there's a lack of funds there's a lack
of personnel so maybe you've you can get
down there but you don't have the
resources to or there's places where you
just physically can't get and that's
Breaking Bad made a really good case for
a giant vat of acid which you know
because interesting okay that's great
problem
then in your credit card history there's
a giant that of bone dissolving acid
body be gone like three Vats where do
you
keep so if they come looking for the
visiting person you're like ignore the
vat in my garage yeah yeah and then
exactly or and then you have to make up
like that's how I cook my my turkey
you've heard of deep frying I just put
it in acid for three minutes I do think
construction zones are pretty effective
too like they just build on top of it
that no one will ever look for it you
have to break an entire building to find
a bike that's what I would do so you you
would go you would find an find a
construction zone and then just kind of
dump it really deep there and then try
to like if you knew when they were
pouring the concrete ideally yes yes
that's good that's good
are we okay keep in mind someone my legs
are very long just keeping remember how
long my legs are I'm just saying because
I know what you're thinking no I don't
know like I love this new library why
are these long skinny legs sticking out
oh yeah I don't know about that and
everyone would know it was me if you did
get murdered I would not there wouldn't
even be a well there would be quite a
few suspects but I think they would know
it would be me uh yeah Sona wrote a very
popular book all about uh our our uh our
strange relationship yeah and um and the
subtext of it is uh I'd like to kill my
boss yeah yeah it's really sweet yeah so
anyway that will be evidence if anything
part of the book
um you wrote a novel I did uh and this
is your first novel I I uh my hat's off
to you it's a huge success thank you
yeah uh all good people here tell me
what led to you writing this novel so I
had this story because it's a fiction
novel a little bit away from my True
Crime background and I had this story
kind of in the back of my head after
hearing so many cases again what's the
perfect crime what are the mistakes that
made this idea that we all think we know
what's happening in a case and can pass
judgment when really we have no idea
what's happening and for the longest
time I just didn't know what to do with
that story because it didn't fit into my
True Crime world I didn't think it would
make a good fictional podcast didn't
want to confuse what we were doing and
podcasting and so finally I decided you
know if this is going to be anything I
think it's I think it's big enough that
it could be a book and I had no idea if
it was going to work but you don't know
until you try I thought the same thing
about the podcast and I gave it a go and
it was a number one New York Times
bestseller that's fantastic it worked
yeah that's fantastic and do you think
you're going to write more of them I do
yeah I really want to do another uh
novel like all good people here and then
I also want to do uh something more
young adult
um like a modern day Nancy Drew I was
reading Nancy Drew the other day and
realized I would like never read it to
my daughter it's just is it pretty uh
it's sexist yeah yeah it doesn't quite
hold up
I could see that I used to read
Encyclopedia Brown yeah and um that was
one that was for
but the crimes were always just things
like that chocolate bar went missing I
know you know and and and I think come
on encyclopedia but let's step it up a
little bit you know I found it's clear
to me who ate the chocolate bar and then
the answer was always written at the
back of the book like upside down uh you
know how how Encyclopedia Brown cracked
it it's quite simple really he said and
then you find out how he did it the guy
had like chocolate on his face
old chocolate McGee ate it yeah exactly
uh so I don't know I think that's um I
think that's cool I think that's cool
and I would I would encourage you I
think that's
that's a great Niche I think I think
young women like being able to read
young adults if it's great when women
can read
yes
yes I suppose it is you know
I used to be against it
and and In fairness so very recently
yeah about five years ago I came around
you know I yeah your daughter would read
and you'd be like why what is going on
you don't
you should be baking a pie
read this Nancy Drew yeah
so but I'm glad you talked to me Sona
and you know and and convinced me I'm
really glad I did too yeah I changed
your opinion on that your position and
now I also think she should be able to
vote
so I'm getting there slowly yeah yeah
we're almost there a white man on our
side
a very slow to convert Ally uh Ashley uh
so happy to get to talk to you and uh
it's funny because
um technically it's it's supposed to be
work that we get together and have an
interview and then it's available on on
the podcast but uh this does not work at
all like I I do feel like if we were
snowed in and trapped in a diner for
like six days we would just be talking
about murder I wouldn't even know it was
six days it would not know six days well
the food would start to go back and then
you'd know and I would really start to
stink uh but
um thank you so much for doing it uh
Ashley flowers uh crime junkie uh the
biggest podcast in the history of
podcasts so uh congratulations to you
and thanks for doing this thank you this
is great